hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my Game of Thrones episode 7 Q&A
video all kinds of stuff to talk about
Lady Stoneheart valonqar Arya Fight Club
theory so just careful for spoilers if
you haven't seen it yet there are so
many Game of Thrones theories colliding
in this episode but one of the new ones
was Arya Fight Club so I try to address
all of these in the questions that I
picked so on top of all that they've
confirmed the titles of the last three
episodes next week's episode episode 8
is called no 1 so it'll probably be the
resolution to arias storyline episode 9
is battle of the bastards so we'll get
Snowbowl but the stuff they have going
on between the crown and the faith in
King's Landing is so big I don't know if
they can skip an episode with that
storyline episode 10 is called the winds
of winter which is fairly
self-explanatory heavy on White Walkers
heavy into the transition to the next
phase of Game of Thrones so they're like
big acts as you break all the novels up
you have the actual game of Thrones just
people competing for the Iron Throne
then you have the larger war for the
dawn storyline so as the series has gone
from season to season it's become less
and less about the battle for the Iron
Throne in more and more about the larger
conflict so that's what's going to be
going on in episode 10 it'll mark the
big transition point from characters
pointing at their enemies going you're
totally screwed to everyone pointing at
each other saying we are all totally
screwed here we go there are questions
mark asks hey Charlie has the Hound
returned to Game of Thrones
how can his storyline connect to the
main plot Lady Stoneheart
well so George are Martin has said that
they're actually skipping Lady
Stoneheart I'm assuming he's being
correct so I think most people are
expecting his storyline to wrap around
with his brother the mountain down in
King's Landing
it's not confirmation of Ko gain bow but
you see what's going on with the hounds
arc you see that he really feels bad
about the terrible things that he's done
he wants to find a way to atone so what
is a really easy way for him to do that
well one that story is all about him
becoming the Hound again like oh I can't
I can't completely leave this life
behind but maybe I can still do some
good so I think he'll still be just as
hardcore as he's always been
he'll just be fighting for what he
thinks is a good cause and what better
cause than getting rid of something as
evil as his brother so yeah there's
still a couple hoops you have to jump
through because he doesn't know about
zombie Mountain yet but I feel like
that's the storyline where he would be
of most use next question JD asks do you
think that Ramsey's a faceless man hired
by the iron bank to displace Lannisters
for defaulting on their massive debt
that was just an awesome comment some of
these from Twitter I thought that was
just an amazing idea no I don't think
that he's a faceless person I think he's
exactly what the show says he is just
you know a bastard from the north it's a
total madman that's taken over you're
not really a character on Game of
Thrones until you're secretly some other
character or secretly a Targaryen so
it's all part of the fun but I don't
think there's any secret history behind
Ramsay I think he's exactly the way the
show's presented him he just Roose
Bolton's bastard trying to make his way
in the world he just also happens to be
a psychopath
next question art bug asks does Theon
has to be an alcoholic now to remain
Theon are you talking about the scene
where he's like he's drinking and that
prove that you're still Theon by
drinking this mug so I think what's
happening is this is just him retaking
his identity book Theon descends to this
subhuman level that's way lower than TV
show Theon ever went to so the process
of him retaking his identity as Theon is
an even bigger deal so I think the TV
show is just like a condensed version of
this next question double-o asks what if
aria is actually dead and the wait takes
her face and we think it's aria for the
rest of the story only for a massive WTF
reveal well so I like the idea that
something weird is going on with the
arch storyline but I do think that she's
alive
I think the version the show is going
with it's just a little more
straightforward the first time I watched
all those Aria scenes the way I read it
is that it's just a straight-up test of
her abilities can you survive this a
face will be added to the hall one way
or another so it's either gonna be the
way for Aria so my initial read of that
is that aria just gonna have to prove
herself and it's gonna be a resolution
to the conflict between her and the waif
that's been going on even though that
really isn't a thing in the books
there's no big Aria battle with a wave I
think the TV show added that line for
pure action just so that there was more
going on in Aria storyline than was
going on in the books so like sometimes
the TV show will cut certain plot lines
out because it doesn't have time to
include those new characters and
sometimes it will add new drama to
characters storylines that didn't exist
in the books like Sansa with ramsay last
season just because they have to include
certain characters each season
and they don't want them to just sit
around and do nothing like if Santa had
been booked accurate during season five
instead of going back to Winterfell she
would have just stayed in the veil and
sat around hiding out so I think they're
kind of doing the same thing with Aria
storyline where they're like they're
upping the action so that it's just a
little more exciting to watch
next question workers asks does anybody
else think that the Buddy from the
Brotherhood is LEM Lemon cloak from the
books the cloak look awfully distinct
yeah I even think that the actor
confirmed that he was Lemon cloak after
the episode so if you haven't read the
books the reason everyone was asking
about Lemon cloak is because he's a
character associated with Lady
Stoneheart in the Brotherhood without
banners he's also someone who has the
hounds helm so there's one of a couple
different things that could be going on
with this storyline they could be doing
Brotherhood without banners because
they're doing Lady Stoneheart and they
want LEM Lemon cloak to kind of tip that
off or he could be there to help the
hound retake his identity as the hound
in the books he comes into possession of
the hounds helm so this could be a way
for the TV show to help the Hound become
the Hound again like literally become
the Hound as he wears the helm again but
even if they wind up not doing Lady
Stoneheart just keep your eyes peeled
for Easter eggs for her storyline
because hanging Ian McShane is already
kind of an Easter Egg for her in the
books that's her signature move she just
hangs anyone that she feels is
associated with the red wedding so if
your last name is Frey if you ever talk
to a Frey you get hung next question
Saurav asks if cleganebowl is to happen
how will it happen I mean how will they
contact Sandor Clegane so yeah you're
asking like how is he gonna get back to
King's Landing how is he gonna learn
about it I would assume it has something
to do with what's going on in the
Riverlands now but Jamie's storyline
unless the Hound makes a beeline for the
north the next closest place would be
Riverrun where this big battle is going
on next question G evil asks do you
think that since house Mormons pledged
their fighting men to Jon Snow
one day Rickon will have to marry Lady
Lyanna Mormont and unite their houses
makes sense I will say yeah definitely
as long as Rickon survives to the end of
the season or to the end of the series
it's a real big question mark but yeah
Rickon would be the clear choice like oh
you're about the same age so why don't
we get you betrothed you'll get married
someday but a lot of times betrothal
--zz don't last very long Sansa was
betrothed
offering for a little while that did not
stick next question Adele asks I think
that Jaime will kill Cersei in the last
episode so I don't know if you're
talking about balint car but do remember
that the Val car is all about Cersei
being killed by a younger brother Jaime
was born after Cersei making him her
younger brother book Jaime has a much
more redemptive arc he's already
recognized how awful Cersei is they
haven't had sex in a long time he's
completely swore her off like he's just
completely written her off she goes way
crazier in the book she gains a ton of
weight she starts to go paranoid so I
think what the TV show is doing is
trying to be more ambiguous with how
it's portraying Lena Headey version of
the character it doesn't want to make
her seem like the clear villain in order
to do that you have to of other
characters sympathizing with her so I
think that is why they've made TV show
Jaime's seem so much more awful but it
is totally possible that he could be the
one to kill her just recognize how
terrible she is but in order for that to
happen she'd have to go a little bit
crazier so I'm just hoping that Cersei
does something completely irredeemable
Jaime recognizes that she's crazy and
there's nothing to be done about it and
he pulls a queen Slayer moment on her
but thank you so much for so many
questions these are always a ton of fun
to do there'll be a couple more bonus
videos this week so just stay tuned for
that congratulations to this week's
giveaway winner - HT DEP you win a $20
Amazon gift card be sure to private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details that's
just on the about page so I'll start a
new round the next time I post a bonus
video so that'll either be like Thursday
or Friday if you have any special
requests just leave them in the comments
I might talk a little bit more about the
Aria Fight Club theory it's a really
interesting theory but I'm not totally
sure that the show is trying to do that
twist so while you guys wait for my next
video to post you can click here for
this week's episode and you can click
here to learn all about brains
flashbacks like the special flashbacks
that he had in the last big episode
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you